الكبير في عمله نادره وفي كل ما يقدم اصلا
جمال سليمان ضيف تفاعلكم هو الشخصيه
الاشهر على المنصات الايام الماضيه وداد
بنت فتوح تدافع عن نفسها عندنا هو نقيب
الفنانين يكشف حقيقه تهزيء محمد سعد
للعاملين في كواليس مسلسله اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
جمل سليمان من اشهر نجوم العالم العربي
وفي هذا الرمضان بيعود الى احد ملاعبه
المفضله الدراما الصعيديه مسلسل عمر نادره
عمل صعيدي بيتكلم عندنا على السلطه
والثروه وبتناول كمان مشكله ميراث المراه
في المجتمع اللي بتدور احداث المسلسل فيه
وبيقدم جمل سليمان شخصيه الكبير عبد
الجبار كبير العيله والمنطقه واللي عنده
ازدواجيه مبادئ مع مصالح
قسما بالله لاطخه بنفسي ومعنى من القاهره
النجم الكبير جمال سليمان اهلا فيك معانا
ومنورنا
مساء الخير ساره كل عام وانت بخير ينعاد
عليك وعلى كل الناس اللي عم يشوفونا
بالخير والصحه وانت بالف صحه وسلامه يا رب
وطبعا انا عندي ضغوط عليا شديده من غرفه
الكنترول كلهم بحييوك وبيسلموا عليك وبشده
وتحديدا طبعا كمان في عندي فريق عمل
تفاعلكم الاعداد يعني زينه وسلام ينقل لك
محبتهم الشديده كمان وقالوا لي انه انا لو
ما بلغتك هذه الرساله رح نفصل
الناس الرائعه اللي معك ساره كل عام
والجميع بخير ان شاء الله وانا مبسوط اني
اكون معك كل رمضان ما تنسينيها
حتى لو ما كان عندي مسلسل
فيك اصلا خلاص حتى لو ما عندك مسلسل لازم
يعني نتكلم معاك اصلا يعني طبعا انت يعني
ما راح اقعد اتكلم الان عن شخصيتك الرائعه
والكلام هذا كله خلاص الكلام على الجنب
خليني اتكلم معاك عن العمل
اول شيء الدقن انت محافظ عليها من العمل
اللحيه
طبعا
لانه انا الحقيقه خلصت تصوير
امبارح الصبح حوالي الساعه سبعه الصبح بعد
24 ساعه اتعمل متواصله وبعدين
كنت بدي احلق دقني بعدين قررت انه ما مره
واحده على مراحل فاسرتها شوي وراح اشوف
يعني خلال كم يوم اذا كنت راح اشيلها
نهائيا ولا خليها ولناسبتك اللوك شكلها
صح خاصه مع الشيب
بس لا يعني خلاص نرجع للوك القديم احسن
احس مدري هذا رايي الشخصي يلا عشان كده
متكبرك
لان المهم
خلاص لا تدقق
فيه احنا بنشوف انك انت يعني بترجع
للدراما او نوعيه الدراما اللي حبوك الناس
فيها ولا انت كمان حاببها اكثر اللي هي
الدراما الصعيديه يعني
اي صحيح انا الحقيقه بحب اللهجه الصعيديه
بحب البيئه الصعيديه وبحب علم الصعيد يعني
لما طبعا بيجيني انا كتير عروض لمسلسلات
صعيديه يعني لانه لو بدي انا امثل كل
مسلسل يشتغل بكل مسلسل صعيد نعرض عليه كان
ممكن اكثر من عشر مسلسلات بس يعني انا كل
ما كان في عندي فرصه اني مسلسل صعيدي حلو
فبيبقى قلبي ميال يعني على قوله فايزه
احمد انا يعني فانا قلبي ميال للمسلسلات
الصعيديه خاصه لما بتبقى مكتوبه بشكل جيد
ولما حكى معي الدكتور مدحت العدل السنه
فانا تحمست جدا لانه انا بحب قلم الدكتور
مدحت بحب كتاباته وسبب نحن اشتغلنا مع بعض
بقصه حب والشوارع الخلفيه وبتابع انا
الدكتور مدحت واللي بيكتبوا سواء بالدراما
او بالمقالات او بالشعر بحب قلمه بحب
دائما انه الدكتور مدحت يعني بيعمل شغله
يعني ممتعه ولطيفه بس بنفس الوقت تبقى
حمله يعني هيك رسائل مفيده للناس بس في
نفس الوقت يعني عشان انت قلت انك ما بتحب
انك تكرر نفسك والكلام هذا كله لو نيجي
لعمله نادره ايش نقدر نقول الاختلاف اللي
جذبك اللي هذه القصه تحديدا
بمعنى مراد الفنانه الرائعه
طبعا جوانا مراد ورجع بعدين
مقتول احنا عنا الاسراء وعنا سميره بنات
مسعود وزوجات مسعود وعلاء يعني الزوجات
اولادي يعني فنحن بنشوف كل امراه من فيهم
حتى يعني زوجه عبد الجبار سكينه بنشوف كل
امراه من النساء اللي موجودين بالمسلسل
الحياه عندها مشكلتها وعندها ماساتها
وبتحس انه هي محرومه يعني من حقه ومن
مكانتها
يعني في المجتمع فهذا شيء يعني يعني مهم
ضروري انه ينطرح بالدراما ومطروح بمسلسل
العمله نادره بعتقد بطريقه لطيفه وجميله
ومقنعه وانسانيه وصادقه لا صحيح هو كل
شخصيه يعني لها معاناتها المختلفه يعني
حتى بنت عبد الجبار كيف بدنا مكمله
تعليمها بس في نفس الوقت عايشه في وسط
قواعد يعني قديمه وبتحب واحد ومدري ايش
قصه حزينه الصراحه يعني
انت قلت انه المسلسل منحاز للمراه طب جمال
سليمان منحاز للمراه كمان
اكيد طبعا من غير تردد قلت
لا لا والله لا مو متردد طبعا انا منحاز
للمراه يعني لانه بنحز الحق لانه انا
صحيح يعني نحن اذا منتابع خلال الخمسين
عام اللي مضوا بنشوف انه وضع المراه
بالعالم العربي تقدم يعني بشكل يعني كويس
بشكل ملحوظ بس ما فينا ندعي بانه المراه
فعلا حصلت على كل حقوقها وعلى مكانتها
الاجتماعيه وبعدين نحن بالعالم العربي
الحقيقه بنلاقي في التباينات واختلافات
اجتماعيه يعني بالوقت اللي ممكن نلاقي
نساء فعلا يعني اخذين حقهم ومقدرين
اجتماعيا
بمناطق معينه بنلاقي بمناطق اخرى او
بشرائح اجتماعيه اخرى لا تزال المراه
تتعرض الى تمييز وتتعرض الى حيف او
بالمناسبه يعني انا يعني فرصه لاني يعني
ابدي اعجابي ووجه تحيه للتقدم الكبير اللي
حصل في يعني مساله المراه في السعوديه
يعني هذا كمان شيء
[موسيقى]
في زملائي جالسين في الكنترول روم بيقولوا
انك انت من احسن من قدم الشخصيات
الصعيديه وهم مصريين فهذا يعني هم جالسين
بيعطوك هذا الشيء اللي بيقولوا بس كمان
لازلنا بنشوف بعض الناس اللي بيقولوا انه
لا جمال سليمان ممثل سوري ليش بيجيبوا في
هذه الادوار فبين هذه الاراء المختلفه هل
لازال يزعجك الموضوع اصلا
لا والله والله ابدا ساره انا صرت يعني ما
بهتم ولا بنتبه يعني انا منتبه لنقد
بمكانه يعني اكيد لا انا كفنان شغلي كامل
وخالي من العيوب ولا الاعمال اللي بيشتغل
فيها خاليه من العيوب وما بعتقد انه يعني
الكمال لله عز وجل يعني
فاكيد كل عمل فني وكل فنان ممكن انه يوجه
له نقد في بعض المشاهد في بعض المواقف في
بعض اللحظات الدراميه ممكن ما يكون مقنع
هذا كلياته شيء الواحد لازم يحترمه ويقدره
ويسمعه لكن احيانا في كلام الحياه بشويه
ما بنسمعه وبعدين انا صرت قايل كتير يعني
مجاوب كتير يعني يعني انا يعني مليت مثل
من كثر ما قلت يعني هل عمر المختار هذا
الرجل يعني اللي من الثقافه غربيه مختلفه
وزلمه امريكاني وكذا طب لما انطوني كوين
قصدي لما شفناه عم يعمل دور
الشيخ عمر المختار يعني هل في حدا انا
صدقا لما شفت عم يعمل عمر المختار نسيت
انه هو عم يحكي انجليزي يعني حسيت ان هو
عم يحكي عربي من شده ما اقنعني المساله
مالها يعني ما بتنطرح بهالطريقه يعني في
كلام الواحد لازم يتجاوزه وخاصه اليوم مع
السوشيال ميديا
فالسوشيال ميديا مثل ما عم تخلينا يعني
نقرا كتابات ونسمع اصوات ناس رائعين شباب
وصبايا ويعني مختلف الاعمار مختلف البلدان
العربيه في الحقيقه ماده غنيه ورائعه
ومشرقه وبتبعث على التفاؤل لكن كمان بنفس
الوقت بتشوفي ناس يعني بتقول كلام يعني
احيانا يعني شوي ما له بمكانه خلينا نقول
هيك
لما انتوا اصلا بس يعني بشكل عام اصلا في
المسلسل بس عشان نوضح معاكم اصلا احد مدقق
للهجه واصلا هو يبدو انه كل مكان اصلا في
الصعيد في فروق بين اللهجات يعني ما هي
واحده موحده اه طبعا حسب ما يعتقدوا النفس
الصعيد لهجات لا لا واحيانا اللهجه بتختلف
بين نجعين المسافه بينهم عشره كيلو متر
فقط الصعيد في لهجته وعلى فكره يعني حتى
نحن بهذا المسلسل احيانا كنا نقول اشياء
فمدقق اللهجه عيدنا يقول هذا يعني مزبوط
الصعايده بيقولوا هيك بس نحن بدنا نوحد
اللهجه نحنا بدنا ناخذ المنطقه اللي هي
جينا بدنا نعمل اقرب ما يكون للهجه اهل
قنا يعني انه سوهاج عند اللهجه وجينا عند
اللهجه والاسوان عندها لهجه وبيناتهم في
النجوع والمناطق في لهجات مختلفه الصعيد
مش لهجه وحده فقط طب لو دخلنا على شخصيه
عبد الجبار اللي بتقدمها طبعا يعني هي
الشخصيه لها كاريزما رهيبه يعني صراحه
وبعدين وانت واقف ما شاء الله يعني مع
طولك وكذا واللبس وتصير بتطالع في كل
زملائك كده على تحت وكده ففعلا بتحس انك
انت الكبير
له كاريزما كبيره اسمع انا بدات كاني
بتكلم كانه بغازلك جمال
حبيبه قلبي يا ساره
بسبوسه في المشهد لانه فعلا في المشاهد
كده بيبين وهو شخص يعني عنده جبروت رهيب
بس في نفس الوقت يعني لما انت طالع فيه
مثير للاعجاب انت في بالك يعني سمعت كان
في شخصيه معينه بنات عليها الشخصيه هذه
الحقيقه طبعا يعني في كسل شخصيه احيانا في
ناس يعني بتسمعي عن جبروتهم وبتسمعي عن
قسوتهم وبتسمعي قديش مخيفين فبتلتقي فيهم
بتكتشفي انهن غيف اللطف وغايه في الطيبه
وبياسروكي بحديثهم
البشر حمالين اوجه
وفي ناس بيبقوا مميزين جدا بهذا الشيء
يعني مثل ما بيكون في شده وقسوه بيبقى في
حنان بيبقى في عاطف احيانا بيبقى في
اندفاع وقرارات حاسمه واحيانا بيبقى في
هدوء وتروي بالوقت للاخرين بتوقعوا انه
هذا الشخص سوف يعني ياخذ قرارات حاسمه
وقاطعه في هذه اللحظه بتفاجئوا انه لا
استنوا خلونا نفكر بالموضوع ما بياخد قرار
بسرعه هدول الناس دائما بيفاجئونا فطبعا
يعني في كذا ريفرنس كان بذهني طب في رفر
جد معينه تقدر تحب تقول لنا هي
الحقيقه انا ضليت فتره طويله يعني مهتم
بشخصيه الرئيس صدام حسين
وتقريبا يعني سمعت كل الشهادات واريد كتير
كتبوا وبعدين تابعت معظم الفيديوهات اللي
موجوده
يعني
بالصوت وصوره الرئيس صدام حسين
وبعدين سمعت خصومه قديش بيكرهوه وسمعت
الناس اللي بيناصروه قديش بحبوه
وجهه نظر فيها تناقض شديد فقلت حتى من هذا
الرجل عنده وجوه عديده كل واحد يعني بقيمه
من خلال يعني
معرفته فيه ومن خلال الوجه هاي اللي شافوا
بالرئيس صدام حسين
فانا اولا اكتشفت انه يعني هو رجل عنده
كاريزما قويه جدا
اثنين هو الشخص ممكن يكون يعني غضوب وحاسم
بدرجه يعني تصل الى حدود قصوى من
القسوه يعني بيبقى يعني ردود فعله قويه
وحاسمه وممكن يدمر كل شيء حواليه
واحيانا بيبقى شخص متبسط ومستمع ومتامل
وممكن يكون صاحب نكته كمان بنفس الوقت
الشخصيه هاي لفتت نظري يعني انا استوقفتني
كتير وطبعا يعني تعرفت على ناس كانوا
يعرفوا شخصيا وقريت عنه كتير وعرفت يعني
الصباغه والشباب فهي الشخصيه يعني الحياه
غنيه جدا
[موسيقى]
وجوه متعدده في اختلاف عليها هو شخص يعني
في لحظه بتلاقيه يقوم بيصلي وعنده مبادئ
في لحظه ثانيه بتلاقيه بيسوي شيء شرير
لاقصى درجه تعامله مع بنته في حنيه غريبه
يعني التعامل مع البنت كمان وفي كمان قسوه
يعني غريب غريب انسان فعلا يعني موجود في
الواقع حقيقه صراحه
يعني واحد بيتجوز كل العادات والتقاليد
وبخلي بنته تروح وتصير طبيبه وتدرس
بالجامعه وبالاخره وتصير طبيبه وتروح على
المستشفى وتعالج رجال وتعالج نساء والى
اخره بس لكن بنفس الوقت غير مسمح لك تتزوج
الرجل اللي هي بتحبه
لسبب بسيط لانه هو ما بيحب ابوه فهو هو
شخصيه ذاتيه جدا الناس الذاتيين واللي
عندهم ايجو كبير مو بالضروره يكونوا بخلاء
او مثلا يكونوا سيئين دائما مع الناس
لانهم بيحبوا الناس ممكن يكونوا بكرمه
ويساعدونا بس هو من وجهه نظره يعني كل
الاشياء ترى من خلال عيونه صعب انه يشوف
الاشياء العيون حتى ثانيه حتى لو كان اقرب
الناس اله مثل بنته مثلا صحيح طيب بدي
استغل وجودك معانا جماله اسالك عن السنه
يعني يمكن اكثر من السنه الماضيه شفنا
عوده لاعمال سوريه خالصه اكثر يعني هذا هل
تابعت شيء منها ايش رايك في هذه العوده في
مديحك الكثير من الاعمال السوريه اللي
موجوده وما بتحدث عن الاعمال المشتركه انا
بتحدث عن الاعمال السوريه
والله انا يعني
فيها يعني تصوير ما تسنى لي انه يشوف غير
يعني
بضعه حلقات واحيانا جزء من حلقه بمسلسلات
يعني لفت نظري طبعا عاصي الزند مسلسل
معمول بصنع يعني كبيره جدا
لفت نظري ايضا مسلسل ابتسم ايها الجنرال
ايضا يعني مبزول في جهد كبير ومسلسل جريء
واشكالي
وفاتح نقاش كتير كبير
ومتجاوز يعني الخطوط التقليديه المعروفه
يعني بصناعه الدراما
لفت نظري ايضا مسلسل العربجي الحياه في
بلشيء اللي شفته انا في شغل يعني على
الصعيد التمثيل وعلى صعيد الاخراج يعني
ايضا ملفت فيه اه في عوده للدراما السوريه
جيده هذا العام وحتى بالاعمال المشتركه
انا لفت نظري مثلا
النار بالنار
حبيت كتير يعني اداء التمثيلي بالمسلسل
يعني رغم اني انا ما اتسنى لي انه يشوف
كتير يعني هذا اللي بتذكر من الاشياء اللي
شفتها بالنسبه للدراما السوريه يعني
والفنانين السوريين بوجهلهم جميعا تحيه
والحمد لله يعني انه يعني دراما السوريه
ترجع شيئا فشيئا لسابق تالقها يعني وهذا
بفضل يعني اخلاص ومحبه الفنانين السوريين
لفخر الصناعات السوريه اللي هي الدراما
السوريه كل الظروف القاسيه والصعبه عم
يقدروا يعني يعملوا شيء فعلا يعني هذه
عوده قويه ومتوقعين انه في السنين القادمه
كمان العوده حتكون اقوى واقوى ان شاء الله
يا رب انا بشكرك دائما على وجودك معانا
وانت دايما بتنورنا وانت عارف يعني انت
معزتك وغلاوتك عندنا
فشكرا لك
على جالسين في الجاليري يقولولي ساره انه
خلاص يعني مره صار واضح كانك بتغازلي فيه
قلت له هو فاهمني هو فاهمني خلاص ماشي
الحال
حبيبه قلبي يا ساره انت غاليه وعزيزه
وتحياتي لكل الزملاء عندك يعني في
الاستوديو وفي الجاليري وعلى الفلور وكلهم
تسلم ليش شكرا لك كان من القاهره النجم
الكبير جمال سليمان
[موسيقى]
بدا عرض مسلسل النار بالنار والجدل مرافقه
في كثير من الامور ان كان بالمشاهد او
القصه والسيناريو او حتى الكلام اللي
بيتكلموا فيه بين بعضهم في المسلسل في
العمل بجثه قصه حي تغيرت تركيبته السكانيه
من بعد الحرب السوريه ونزوح السوريين
واستقرارهم فيه وبتناول المشكلات
والصراعات اللي بتصير فيه وكان كاتب العمل
رامي كوسا ووضح من خلال منشورات متعدده
على صفحه الشخصيه انه في تعديلات كثيره
على السيناريو والقصه هو مو عاملها وحقيقه
كان في مشاهد عملت جدل اكثر من غيرها مثل
خلع مريم اللي بتقوم بدورها النجمه كنيسه
بشار خلعها للحجاب علشان تطلع جواز سفر
واوراق جديده ومثل مشهد كمان الاخذ والرد
بين عزيز اللي هو جورج خباز ومريم اللي هي
كريس بشار واللي الناس شافوا فيه عنصريه
او غيره من المشاهد اللي عملت الجدل وامس
كان في مشهد تصدر المنصات وعمل حاله تفاعل
كبيره بين الناس وهو كمان بين عزيز ومريم
والمشهد كان بدا بخناقه كبيره وضرب وانتهى
بدمعه وابتسامه
صفات مريم العزيز قلبت المنصات
وعلى فكره كل الجدل اللي حوالين المسلسل
كان طلع مخرج ومحمد عبد العزيز من ساعات
ورد على بعض الاجزاء المتعلقه فيه فقال
انه مشهد خلع الحجاب ما بيحرض على لبس
الحجاب او خلعوه ابدا وانه التعديلات اللي
كاتب المسلسل بيتكلم عنها تمت على عده
مراحل تحت اشراف الشركه المنتجه للعمل
وبموافقه الكاتب اللي ابدا في بدايه الامر
مرونه كبيره لكن في مرحله ما وصلوا الى
طريق مسدود وانه الفنانين المشاركين في
العمل امثال عابد فهد وكريس بشار وجورج
خباز وطوني عيسى اثر العمل
بملاحظاتهم وان العمل صار في مناخ خيمت
عليه يروح الفريق الواحد
[موسيقى]
وليه قلت لكم قلب الدنيا على راس وداد في
الواقع لانه ببساطه ردات الفعل من متابعي
المسلسل على المشهد فقط التوقعات
اما جوري فكانت شافت رداد الفعل ويبدو
انها تاثرت فيها ونشرت ستوري من ايام قالت
فيها ان هذا التمثيل وطلبت من متابعين
مسلسل انه يتوقفوا عن السب والشتيمه وانه
هذا الشيء بياذيها نفسيا
ومعنى من القاهره الفنانه جوري بكر اهلا
فيك معنا يا جوري يعني انت ترند صار لك كم
يوم في كل الوطن العربي
الحمد لله اهلا بك يا ساره وشكرا جدا على
الاستضافه الجميله دي جدا
وما شاء الله العمل محقق نجاح يعني كبير
بس يعني خلينا نقول انه الناس معصبه من
شخصيتك جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا يعني
الموضوع وصل انك انت تقولي للناس بس كفايه
شتيمه ايش صار
دي حقيقه فعلا انا ما كنتش متوقعه ان انا
هبقى مستفزه قوي كده غير لما شفت نفسي على
الشاشه انا شخصيا كرهت كرهت الشخصيه كرهت
وداد جدا يعني حتى اللي حواليا كلهم حرفين
كرهوها
بس يعني لما ايش صار لك ايش يعني انت جاتك
اتصالات ولا على السوشيال ميديا وين كان
السب يعني والشتيمه والتهديد
السب والشتام ابتدى من على السوشيال ميديا
ناس كتير جدا وناس يمكن حرفيا قريبين مني
كانوا بيشتموا او بيحاسبنوا بيقولوا حاجات
صعبه جدا انا يمكن علشان يعني
نجاح المفروض ان اللي حصل ده نجاح
والمفروض ان انا اتقبل الموضوع ده بس انا
يمكن عشان لسه يعني عشان لسه انا جوايا
انا كجوري وبتصرف ان انا كجوري وخلاص خلصت
المسلسل ده فبقول انتوا بحس الشتايم دي او
السب ده او الاهانات دي كلها بتضرني انا
او بتضر الناس المتابعين ليا سواء اهلي او
او زوجي او اصدقائي اللي حواليا انه
يشوفوا كلام جارح على صوره من صوري فحسيت
ان الكلام ثقيل هم قالوا لي احنا مش بنكره
جوري احنا بنكره وهي فعلا شخصيه وداد
تستاهل كل كلمه اتقالت عليها طب انت عروسه
جديده جوري طبعا يعني مبروك بس انه
ايش راي زوجك في وداد
هو انا متاكده وانا متاكده ان جوزي حاليا
قاعد على الكنبه في البيت بيتفرج على
الحلقه عايزه اقول لك ان هو مبسوط جدا
بالمسلسل فخور بيا بيدعمني من اول يوم
اشتغلت فيه في المسلسل بس هو خايف مني
اوكي كان دايما يقول لي يا جوري اوعي
تعملي فيا زي ما بتعملي في سيد فبقول له
لا هو طبعا حاجه تانيه خالص وبشكره طبعا
ان هو اداني اجازه انزل مصر كم يوم علشان
احتفل بنجاحي وسبته قاعد في قسم لوحده بس
يعني ان شاء الله ربنا يجمعنا مع بعض بس
يعني هو اوفر اويل هو عارف ان جوري ملهاش
اي علاقه ببوتات هو عارف ان انا طيبه جدا
صح يا رامي ههه يعني يعني كنا نحتاج ناخذ
منه مداخله يا جوري يمكن عنده راي مختلف
هو الان بعيد عنك يعني يمكن يقول كلام
ثاني على المهم احنا جايين نهدي النفوس
يعني ما تقلقيش لنا زياره قريب لنا زياره
لينا زياره قريبه ان شاء الله طب بس من
الاساس انت يعني كيف اختارك محمد سامي
لهذا العمل تحديدا هذا الدور
الموضوع ده صدفه بحته جدا انا كنت موجوده
في العرض الخاص مع استاذه مي عمر فتقريبا
هو كان بيدور على الشخصيه دي او يمكن كان
في حد مكاني واعتذر عن الدور فمي استاذه
مي قالت له محمد انا شايفه ممكن جوري تبقى
حلوه جدا في الدور ده وفعلا كلمني استاذ
محمد وقال لي جوري انا عندي دور مهم جدا
وايه رايك قلت له طبعا انا اكيد مع حضرتك
يعني استاذ محمد سامي استاذ محمد رمضان
اكيد مسلسل هيكسر الدنيا ايوه وفعلا هو
لقى كسر الدنيا بس لما قرات الورق بعدين
توقعتي حجم الكراهيه اللي حتواجهيها
لا للاسف يا ساره لا خالص عارفه زي لما
كنت بقرا الورق وبمثل اللي انا شفته على
التلفزيون ولما نزلت الشارع يا نهار ابيض
ما كنتش حاسه ان هي وحشه قوي كده على
الحقيقه في التلفزيون
يعني ما شاء الله النجاح الكبير صارت
الناس جالسه بتفتش وبترجع وبتدور طبعا على
اعمالك وبيقراوا كذا ومش عارفه ايش
بيدخلوا مقابلاتك والكلام ده كله وصار
كتير ناس بيقولوا انك انت حفيده الفنانه
الراحله الكبيره ماري منيب وصاروا بيحطوا
لكم صور مع بعض والكلام ده كله بس اظن
عندنا حتى يعني نحن صوره ايوه الان صور
الان ظاهره على الشاشه لكم انت من العمل
كداد وماري منيب طبعا غنيه عن التعريف
يعني الله يرحمها بس فتوضحي لنا هل فعلا
في بينكم قرابه
اتمنى ده يزيدني شرف لا طبعا بس انا كنت
بحب حركات وشها وانا بحبها جدا وكنت فعلا
بقلدها شويه في مشاهد عشان كده طلعت يعني
كوبي بايست اوكي كنت عندك شفايفك يمكن كنت
حركات قريبه من حركات شفايفها كمان
ما هو انا درست الشخصيه كويس جدا على فكره
ايوه طب الان ما تخافي يا جوري انه بعد
النجاح هذا كله الكبير انه الناس تحصرك في
هذا النوع من الادوار
هذا لا انا خايفه منه بس يعني ان شاء الله
لقى وانا يمكن دلوقتي الفتره اللي جايه
اقدر ان انا اختار الادوار بعنايه كويسه
يعني واقدر اقرا واشوف انا ايه اللي هيليق
عليا وايه اللي مش هيليق عليا بس ممكن
يكون ادوار شعبيه او ادوار بنت فلاحه او
ادوار سعديه انا بحب الادوار اللي هي
بتاعه بنات البلدي بحب الادوار القويه بس
ما يكونش
محصوره في وداد اكون محصوره ممكن في حاجه
شبه الشخص زي محمد رمضان مثلا ما معظم
مسلسلاته بتناشد الشارع او البيوت المصريه
كلها من من البيوت الصغيره ومن الطبقات
الصغيره لاكبر طبق طبقه موجوده عندنا في
البلد انا بحب يعني انا بحب طريقته في
الشغل واتمنى ان انا كمان على المستوى
النسائي ابقى زيه يعني في نفس زي شغله
ايوه طب لما الان انت بتقولي انك انت
متزوجه وقاعده في قطر والكلام هذا كله
برضه بعض الناس بيقولوا انه هذا يمكن ياثر
على مسيرتك يعني الفنيه انه لا ما راح
يفرق يعني
لا خالص بصي مدام مدام احنا الاتنين
متفقين ما دام احنا الاتنين مبسوطين مع
بعض وهو مبسوط بيا ومبسوط بنجاحي وانا
مبسوطه به مبسوط بنجاحي احنا متفقين من
قبل ما نتجوز انه لو ان شاء الله حصل نصيب
واتعرض علي دور كويس هو مش هيمانع ابدا
خالص ان انا انزل مصر واعمله لانه زمان
كنت بقعد اعمل ادوار كتير وبعمل شغل كتير
لمجرد ان انا اخد فرصه
تخليني في المكان اللي انا موجوده فيه ده
دلوقتي بس يمكن الحمد لله دلوقتي النجاح
اللي انا فيه دوت يساعدني بعدين ان انا
اقدر اختار ادوار كويسه بعنايه مش تبقى
يعني تبقى مجرد مسلسلات لوجودي بس في
الوسط لا حاجه تساعدني ان انا ابقى موجوده
كل السيزون اوف سيزون او في رمضان كيف كان
الكواليس التصوير خصوصا في المشاهد اللي
انت فيها العدو وسيد احمد فهيم يعني بيكون
هو المسكين فيها تجسد بتبهدلي فيه كرهناك
يا جوري
دي حقيقه وعايزه اقول لحضرتك كمان ان هو
اصلا واحنا في الكواليس واحنا عارفين انه
تمثيل هم كانوا كارهني فعلا وكنت بخاف
يعني انا كنت بصور الاتجاه ده هم الاتجاه
التاني انا كنت بخاف اعدي الشارع اروح لهم
من كتر ما هم تعبانين ومخنوقين وبيعيطوا
بجد وعايشين الشخصيه يعني من جوه قلبهم
متقمصين الدور جدا والله كنت بخاف وبالذات
استاذه هاله صدقي انا كنت استحاله اقرب
ناحيتها وانا عدوه وانا عدوه استحاله كانت
هتقتلني الملكه صفصف طبعا يعني
كان نفسهم يجيبوا لي من شعري هي حتى كانت
بتقول استاذ محمد هو احنا ينفع نروح
نضربها ونجيبها من شعرها ونخلص من المشهد
ده
طيب ربنا ربنا انقذك على العموم احنا
بنتمنى لك التوفيق الحمد لله وان شاء الله
من نجاح لنجاح يا جوري كانت معنا من
القاهره الفنانه جوري بكر شكرا لك اشكرك
[موسيقى]
الفنان محمد سعد بيشارك في الموسم
الرمضاني في مسلسل اكسلانس ومن اسبوعين
انتشر فيديو من موقع التصوير قلب الدنيا
وعمل جدل كبير وفي ظهر الفنان وهو بيصرخ
وبيبهدل الناس في موقع التصوير واليوم
الموضوع يعني صار في تطورات بس خليني اول
اذكركم بالمشهد
اللي صابر من
قبل ما يفتح
القرف اللي انتم فيه ده ايه العرض ده
انتوا مقرفين قوي
وقرف
ده ايه ده
ده انت اوفر ده انتم ما حدش ده انتم
قاعد بيعالج
ايه اللي مش عاجبه يقول
اللي مش عاجبه كلمه يقول
الفيديو اللي شفتوه عمل جدل وانقسام كثار
انتقدوا اذان وقالوا عيب وفنانين دخلوا
على الخط دعما
وصاروا ينشروا صورهم مع محمد سعد وتضاربت
الانباء حول اللي صاير في الفيديو فاحد
قال انه كان بيصرخ على الطاقم بما فيهم
المخرج ابراهيم نشاته مخرج العمل يعني
طلعت على لسانه تصريحات مختلفه فالمصري
اليوم مثلا نقلوا عنه انه محمد سعد ما كان
بيصرخ على العاملين في المسلسل بل على
الناس من خارج اللوكيشن عطلوا التصوير لكن
شفنا وسائل اعلام تانيه ناقله عن المخرج
تصريح مختلف بيقول فيه انه مشكله محمد سعد
كانت مع المسؤولين عن السيطره على المكان
اثناء التصوير وهو انفعل بسبب فقدهم
للسيطره عليها وفي تصريح ثالث قال المخرج
محمد سعد كان منفعل لانه طلب من طاقم
الانتاج امور وما صارت الجديد اليوم انه
نقيب الفنانين اشرف زكي طلع ودافع عن محمد
سعد وقال انه محمد وقت ما يشارك في اي عمل
بيكون مسؤول عنه تماما وبيتحمل مسؤوليته
وانه اهتمامهم بالعمل بيكون كبير جدا وقال
انه هو شاف الفيديو وانه اللي يعرفوا انه
كان في اشياء طلبها وما تنفذت وانه ما
يعرف بالتحديد على مين كان منفعلوا انه
محمد سعد انسان محترم وابن بلد وان كان
اخطاء فلازم نغفر له الفيديو اللي تسرب مو
كامل ومشتهزا ونحن شفنا رد الفعل بس وليس
الفعل
مشاهدينا نعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في
الخميس الونيس اجول خلاص دخلنا الخميس من
يوم وحلو الخميس اشوفكم